you know so many people are lost today
let me explain to what I mean by this if
you go on social media today you'll see
one video that goes viral by somebody
that's a big influencer two hours later
you'll see somebody else make it and in
trying to be emotional you are such a
good person
you can do something big and then
another person makes it and another
person makes it thinking it's all gonna
go viral but it's not because this guy
did it cuz he was being himself and
you're acting and the other person is
acting and the other person is acting
and it's felt years ago I would give a
speech from stage and I wasn't myself
and it was felt I would record myself
and I would say that wasn't you why were
you not speaking like you why are you
listening to this Toastmaster stuff
that's not you that's not how you talk
talk like you talk like you talk at a
coffee shop or at dinner why aren't you
talking like you talk so many people are
lost today let me read you an excerpt
out of the book that has to do with
Thomas J Watson if you don't know who he
is he's the former founder of IBM here's
what he said once he said IBM is what it
is today for three special reasons the
first reason is that at the very
beginning I had a very clear picture of
what the company would look like when it
was finally done you might say that I
had a model in my mind of what it would
look like when the dream my vision was
in place the second reason was that once
I had that picture I then asked myself
how a company that looked like that
would have to act I then created a
picture of how IBM would act when it was
finally done so again let me recap first
it was what the company would look like
second was how we would need to act
today the third reason watch this the
third reason iBM has been so successful
was that once I had a picture of how IBM
would look when the dream was in place
and how such a company would have to act
I then realized that unless we began to
act that way from the very beginning we
would never get there in other words I
realized that for IBM to become a great
company it would have to act like a
great company long before it ever became
one this is from the book your next five
moves first act like it - how do we have
to behave today three long before you
become
the company that you want it to be we
have to start acting like that from day
one what's he trying to say they found
out their identity and who IBM wanted to
be and who they didn't want to be so
many lost people today because they have
no clue who they want to be this is why
in the book your next five moves move
number one is who do you want to be I
want to give you a story about a couple
people that showed up today
both of them are entrepreneurs ones from
Europe both them I was you only
consulting with the other one is a local
person that's in the restaurant business
the first one is somebody that's a very
very well-known doctor worldwide who has
a hundred hundred one hundred thousand
and one thousand customers that have
bought this person's course but the
pandemic has changed a lot for them they
have money it's not like they're
struggling they're sitting on millions
of dollars of cash but they don't know
what they want to do next they were so
lost very successful multi-millionaire
has sold a hundred and one thousand
courses extremely successful you would
know who this person is we're doing a
consulting call for an hour but they
don't know who they want to be today
because the pandemic has scared the hell
out of everybody
you're not typically doing the speaking
gigs you did before so how do you pivot
how do you just today what do you do
just because you were successful ten
years ago doesn't mean you're successful
today you could have been successful for
successful for twenty years but you're
lost today the other person came in and
they said well we're noticing people are
making money in this side and what if we
go do this so again we know some people
are making this way and with one minute
they want to do this next minute the
wife says I want to do this the other
minutes that they want to do no we want
to do no we won't do this I said what do
you want to do we have these seven
different things we wanted I said that's
the wrong way to go who do you want to
be who do you want to be in today's
marketplace stop looking at everybody
consuming too much content from way too
many different people can completely
confuse the hell out of you because
you're trying to be seven different
characters and you have to step back
turn up all social media
stop following any of these other guys
stop watching what anybody else is doing
sit down by yourself ask the question
who do you want to be that's the
question I had to ask myself who I
wanted to be in the marketplace one the
best advice I ever got was from one of
my former mentors he said something very
powerful to me so the company for 680
million dollars
he once said Pat I learned a long time
ago every time I'm number one I'm broke
so what do you mean he says every
number one go-to guy in a company I
don't make money he says I make so much
money and I'm so much more fulfilled
when I'm the number six guy number three
guy or the number two guy I'm miserable
being a number one guy
this is a person that knows who he wants
to be who do you want to be do you know
the answer to that question do you have
any idea who you want to be do you have
any idea what direction you want to go
have you thought about that this book
move number one is spent the entire
section of what I did to find out
exactly who I want to be when I was 21
years old who I wanted to be at 25 years
old who I wanted to be at 30 years old
at 35 years old who I want to be today
for the next 20 years it's figuring out
who I want it to be and the book was
written specifically to help you no
matter whether you're 16 years old 22
years or 30 years or four years or 50
years old to identify exactly who you
want to be today
well you're not like everybody else
who's lost out there so having said that
this book comes out August 18 if you
haven't yet bought the book your next
five moves you can go to your next
Bibles com and if you buy a copy today
we will send you chapter the book if you
buy three copies of it today maybe you
send it as a gift to other people I not
only will send you a chapter but I also
send you one our strategy session of
four quadrants that I talked about this
is an unlisted private video that it can
only see if you buy the three video
three copies and I'll send it to you so
you know exactly what you need to be
doing today during a crazy time today
this is not a regular time this is not a
time to wing it
this is not a time to be casual this is
time where you got to spend some time
identifying exactly who you want to be
if you want that to be you go buy copy
or go buy three copies and we'll send
you the video and we'll send you to
chapter for you to read way before the
book comes out on August 18 again if you
do want to order the book send us a text
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two again three one zero three
four zero one one three two text next
move to us we'll send you the link and
if you're not in the u.s. if you go to
your next five moves com you'll be able
to place the order of the book your next
five moves that comes out August 18
having said that if you haven't
subscribe to the channel do so thanks
for watching everybody take care bye bye